yes the Deadpool trailer is finally out
I feel like I've already talked about it
it's because I have this trailer is 90%
the same trailer that was revealed at
Comic Con the trees where I already did
a video about so the fact that I'm doing
a video now says that I'm going to spend
an entire video talking about the extra
10% it's probably more like 2% you want
to see me talk about that right there
but I'm going to talk about some more
here be the means I'm the most dedicated
youtuber to his fans or complete
douchebag who'll do a video for any
reason whatsoever in my defense it's
probably both I'm addicted to doing
videos what can I say it's no problem
first of all I'm going to talk about
what they did the day before the day
before there was a teaser trailer to the
trailer it's like a teaser for the
teaser it was movie trailer voice and
it's ultimately you know his Deadpool
talking he's like from the studio that
sewed his mouth shut the first
time I was like all right I still love
this campaign I love how they're doing
Deadpool in this trailer he says don't
make the suit green or animate it and
that's a jab at Green Lantern they're
jabbing at x-men origins Wolverine then
they had that one video where Deadpool
bashes AC Slater over the head with a
stage light I love the meta humor I love
that they're doing it in Deadpool
because that does Deadpool justice I
want to see Deadpool fight the Deadpool
from x-men origins Wolverine you can
have it at the beginning before the
titles you can have it at the end point
is I want Muraki Deadpool from x-men
origins Wolverine to come out in the
dead pools like is that then he can
talk you blow them away
you can even have Hugh Jackman as
Wolverine cameo and Deadpool can be like
I love to half your movies by the way I
have this is cool they can do I
just want to see him kill that piece of
Barak a thing that was in x-men
origins Wolverine I think this movie is
a perfect opportunity to do that but I
did get Fox credit I love the fact that
they're like yeah you can make fun of us
because that was a really stupid ass
thing we did getting into this trailer
they took out the Stanley Cammie the
Stan Lee cameo was in the Comic Con
trailer took it out of here which is
great because I think it's a great cameo
and if you can keep that secret from the
people until the movie comes out to be
perfect I also took out the scene where
when Colossus max Deadpool he calls him
big chrome gobbler I thought he
said block I thought like you know
Colossus blocked his kill and took
it for himself or something I thought
that's just why he called him a
block I guess he calls him a big chrome
gobbler and that's the thing if you
watch a bootleg you're not gonna have
the crisp clear 5.1 audio you're used to
having and then in the comments section
of that severely bootlegged video from
Comic Con I saw a few people like
gobblers an offensive term to
homosexuals can't believe you'd say that
you need to take that out of the movie
and then coincidence
it's not actually in the red band
trailer for this movie which I mean if
they just didn't have it like the
Stanley Camry looks like a little B in
the movie it's just not in the trailer
right now all right whatever
but if they actually took it out of the
movie or changed it because it might
have been offensive to some people I
hate that and though some people
might say I'm a piece of for it I
mean really if you're gonna have a
talker in a movie not be offensive to
anybody he's gonna say things like
poopoo head and you're a dum-dum I saw
that one of my Twilight videos I called
Bella and evil and said she needed
to die almost like this slander is to
women you can't call women that the
point is what I meant was Bella isn't
evil Horan needs to die that's not to
say she sells her body for money she
doesn't I'm kind of going on a tirade
right here because I'm severely against
instr my point is if Fox entered
the movie because it's an offensive term
that I think that's stupid you're
leading to Deadpool getting censured
which would really suck do you want that
do you want pg-13 Deadpool you want a
world where he doesn't call someone a
gobbler really it's just like own
it write it out be like yeah it's in the
movie because that's what he would say I
wish they would have come out with a
different trailer right here that showed
different scenes from what the comic-con
trailer showed but that's neither here
nor there point is people now get to see
it and hide that they get to see a great
trailer Deadpool is still great he's
still the talker
I'm loving the marketing I love how they
have the meta humor everywhere I mean
the possibilities are endless for what
they can do with Deadpool and if they
pull it off in the movie how it looks
like they are pulling it off so the
Deadpool trailer that was very much the
same trailer that was that comic-con but
if I know some of my fans some people
were like I don't want to see a shitty
version of it I want to see the high def
version now you can so what did you
think whatever you thought comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more